as Joe Biden releases his first ad his
wife tries to help your candidate might
be better on
I don't know healthcare than Joe is but
you've got to look at who's gonna win
this election and maybe you have to
swallow a little bit and say okay I sort
of personally like still it so better
swallow a little bit talk about a
ringing endorsement please vote for my
husband he's really not that bad but I
get it it's hard to nail Trump when
everybody's got a job the US economy is
humming along and peace is breaking out
all over so what's left the
psychological and the hypothetical first
the psychological from Joe's ad most of
all he restore the soul of the nation
battered by an erratic vicious bullying
president because things are going well
this attacks now about an emotional
feeling toward a president it's funny
could you imagine any other country
saying please get rid of our leader
because he's a big meanie
or a coach saying Joe has taken us to
the championship but he's a jerk so cut
him if this were a good idea every
brilliant MD would be out of work the
Dems cannot separate Trump's personality
from how well he runs the country they
conflate words with deeds the real world
with the Trump show it saves them from
having to come up with anything better
which they lack then there's a
hypothetical there is no big war but
what if Trump gets us in one there is no
proof of collusion but what if there was
there is no recession yet but what if
there was one maybe the media can talk
when into existence it's been all
hypotheticals for three years at any
moment unstable Trump could lead us
somewhere really bad as he actually
leads us to someplace good but as you
scan their choices for president you got
to feel bad for the Dems their plan pin
the tail on the donkey in a room full of
asses that'll hurt yeah it certainly I
don't even know what it means you never
played that
what pin the tail on a donkey yes I did
but I don't understand the joke I made
is what I'm saying okay they're
targeting feelings yeah but that's what
elections are about mm-hmm it's how you
feel about somebody and yeah I imagine
that they chose the words erratic fish
and bullying because they were
poll-tested yeah focus group to death
and that these are the things especially
women are saying that these are the
things we can't take and so the thing
about the electability argument that his
wife was using is that that doesn't
usually motivate primary voters right
prime it might might motivate you in a
general election if you're like well
it's like one or the other but a primary
is like you want your person you're
really gonna go out there and support
them and she's basically saying he's the
most electable to vote for him and he
and his ad then is having something
different he's like this is a character
contrast that he's trying to push out
the other thing that's happening is that
he's the most electable now until the
warrant and Sanders takes one of them
has to go right and when that when that
coalesce is yes then they will also be
able to make the electability of yes
because then they'll be around for that
person will they will they will they
were like mold into like a 2-headed
socialist monster and they'll have 30%
jesse so they could actually go in front
of Biden and get the plurality I don't
even think if you add those two up
against 230 I think it's like in the mid
20s I think it's like 35 I think I'd be
surprised if it was that hot moderates
then there actually are crazy left-wing
socialist radicals in the party
I agree then I think electability and
experience are overrated in politics
Hillary was the most experienced and she
lost Barack Obama was the least
experienced and he won and remember
Donald Trump was completely unelectable
and he won so you can throw that out the
window right now the American public
believes someone that's experienced in
Washington DC just seems like an insider
that's been there their whole life or
someone that's electable like Joe is
just someone that the pundits predict is
electable and the pundits are always
wrong except me of course by these big
strengths are his association with
Barack Obama and too he's clinging
desperately to that moderate lane by the
by his fingernails but he's been piling
up so many gaffes and he's having a lot
of trouble with these small donors and
they're trying to cut back his schedule
because he's too sleepy and he's just
not inspiring
he doesn't draw any crowds Liz Warren
had about 12,000 the other day Biden I
think hasn't cracked a thousand from the
last couple months that I've seen so
he's also promised to give health
insurance to illegal aliens eliminate
coal and natural gas and raise taxes for
the middle class really really body
blows if you if you look at a general
election but something he's gonna have
to deal with this winter when Spygate is
finally exposed Williams he's gonna have
to answer what did he know and when did
he know it if he knew anything at all
and then if he didn't know anything at
all where was he
yeah Williams electability is the number
one issue for Democrats I don't think is
any question of CNN has a poll out today
and they have close to 60% Democrats
saying we want someone who is proven in
their ability to win against Donald
Trump
and I think Trump is mad he's mad at Fox
and Fox polling because we have an AHA
Madame either one no but in Fox polling
we have four people beating him but the
key for Democrats forget to everybody
that's just Democrats is can you beat
Trump and this is interesting to me what
interesting is he's actually up right
now in the post before he ran this ad he
is increased in the CNN poll by seven
points now back up to 29% you get
Sanders and Warren and I think it's like
15 and 40 inches by 30% Jesse all of
that but the key for me is looking
inside the numbers and when you look
inside the numbers what do you see it's
moderates it's older Democrats some of
the young folks but really strong number
of conservative to moderate Democrats
who are backing Biden they see him as
the alternative to trump in other words
Trump is the bully here's a guy who we
can see is a nice guy
Joe from Scranton who you can trust and
who you a think if this is gonna be a
referendum on Trump he allows it to be a
referendum on Trump because Joe is not
objection I mentioned one thing cuz you
showed that poll I think also look
Kamala Harris had had that bump and then
a complete and the other good news in
that poll is for Julian Castro who's now
made the debate stages up to 2% and by
the way it's a 2 you should know guys he
has put forward a animal welfare plan I
find it interesting that you know this
is a party that is you know it's 2020 a
hundred years after women getting the
right to vote and they're gonna call us
behind a white male born in the 1940s I
know that was when the war took place
gonna place you said electability is
important to Democrats that's true but
it's always miscalculated Mitt Romney is
also another example of someone who beat
Barack Obama that's why everyone had to
go into the moderate lane Joe Biden is
not a nice guy this is a myth that he's
this like nice player on the field he's
actually pretty brutal when it comes to
things that he says on the campaign
trail but if you can't get an
endorsement from your wife or like at
least some enthusiastic support and she
has to stay you're his health care plan
which is the number-one issue among all
voters might not be as good as anyone
else in the field but you should vote
for him anyway yeah they have to talk
about why his policies are better for
Democrats and the country and if they're
not gonna talk about it Elizabeth
Warren's gonna talk about it and she's
the one who's rising in the polls faster
than anyone else yeah my prediction is
this Liz now I've changed same I thought
it was common law yeah but III think liz
has got that energy she's waving her
arms around and dancing you reserve the
right to change your I will change my
mind a mind at least four or five times
before this evening is out okay what
about you plans I know you're gonna go
see a Quentin Tarantino movie ly am I am
I am no I think I don't see how Biden
gets it I think Warren right now has a
lot of momentum I think if you know the
thing about having the wife do it you
know you want surrogates who can inspire
you can up yeah and there's a little bit
of like desperation oh my wife I mean
gosh if your wife didn't endorse you'd
be trouble I mean they could play a
pretty decent and important role on the
campaign trail but when your first
statement out of the gate is he might
not be as good as the rest of you it's
like Joe Biden when he's on stage
he says look for the bark that the dog
that isn't barking yeah it's she's
talking Obama isn't he's going to such a
conventional opinions